[Music]
originally when we first met it was like
i said no i don't want any kids he said
no more kids for him so we're on the
exact same page
well fast forward two and a half years
you know
someone changed the page
just seeing him be such an incredible
dad and i think like that really started
changing my mind i love heather more
than anything so if she she wants to
have a kid of course i would love to
have a child with her
but the couple is facing some fertility
challenges when heather was in her 20s
she found out she had a low egg count
the 34 year old just wrapped her second
round of egg freezing i'm like i want to
do it just as a it's an insurance an
insurance policy yeah
last time i did this i got six healthy
eggs it's definitely been
rough like these last two and a half
weeks poking myself every single day
with needles three times a day the
hormones the emotions finding out at
first we heard i only had two eggs which
going through this whole process and
only getting two eggs i was i was sad i
did cry a little bit and i came out i
had seven eggs so that was like really
exciting for us
we're going to
take tarex you know the good stuff and
create embryos so right now we're
actually tracking it to see how many are
growing and then some don't make it and
then in about a week and a half we'll
find out how many how many made it so
we'll find out how many little babies we
have on ice
we could have yes
we'll probably end up with like three
kids you'll see
lauren he talked about twins the other
day we'll get it done
twins is this real is this really sure i
don't know if i don't know if they'll
fit but yeah well we're keeping the
embryos but we're also still trying the
natural way fun way if we can't get it
done the fun natural way then the
embryos are the backup yeah okay so she
i mean she'd get pregnant any day we
just don't know we are trying yeah we
are we are trying yeah what timeline are
you on now when would you love to be
pregnant we haven't had that talk yet
yeah i think well we're on each other i
know right lauren um
honestly like i think i'm ready sooner
than
i think he'd be ready i'm ready i'm
ready i've already made the decision
we're having a kid i'm obsessed with the
kids i'm going to coach their sports
like i'm going to do it all to have
another kid with heather it's just it's
going to be special
so when do we want to be pregnant
within a year within look at him i'm
like i'm trying to find her to find out
too what do you what do you have next
who the next month no
first
i mean it's been a minute like do you
remember how to change your diapers
don't do that well of course i will i
should i need a helmet a gas mask he
can't he won't do it we've already
decided it's okay he's not going to be
doing diapers i'll do some diapers i'll
do some diapers it's a true thing like i
have a
reflex to wear like yeah she can't even
clean up our dog's poop okay but i try
so if you're not on poop patrol then how
do you make up for it what's the thing
you do
oh i just treat my queen like a queen
exactly so we have our rolls you know
it's okay
[Music]
you